hello and welcome i'm james murphy and
today we're taking a look at
a subtle rule that python has about
variable scopes
let's play a game what does the function
print
let's start with an easy one shout out
the answers as we go
tell me either what it's going to print
or what error it's going to give
let's start with f what do you think
happens when we run it
well of course when we run it we get an
error specifically a
name error okay the first one was really
easy
what about the second one g is it any
different from f
well of course we still get an error but
it's actually a different error
now technically unbound local error
derives from name error
but i think it might be surprising to
many of you that something different
happened at all
somehow python knew that i was going to
assign to x
later in the function normally in python
outside of a looping context we don't
expect statements in a function that are
later in the function
to affect statements that are earlier in
the function
it turns out that whether or not a
variable like x
is determined to be a free variable or a
local variable
is actually determined at compile time
not at runtime
in the function f there are no
assignments to the variable x
so x is determined to be a free variable
that means when we say print
x it tries to look up x in the global
scope and fails
in g however the function does contain
an assignment for x
it says x equals 1. so that means that
in the function g
x is determined to be a local variable
that means that when we try to print x
it looks it up in the local scope
and hence we get a local error not a
global error
keeping that in mind let's look at
another two examples and see if you get
them right
what do you think happens when we call h
we have defined the global variable
y equals 0 before defining the function
and then we try to print y
in the function go on just shout it out
okay this was another easy one it prints
zero
now what do you think happens for the j
function
take your time i'll wait
okay have you locked your guess in here
we go
when i run the j function i get another
unbound local error
now you might look at this and say when
i call j
we have this global variable y that's
defined to be zero
so print y should be printing 0 just
like in the previous case
but that's not how the variable lookup
rules work
because somewhere in the function j
assigns y a value
everywhere in the function y is treated
as a local variable
that means at the beginning when we try
to print y it doesn't even try to look
it up in the global scope it only looks
in the local scope
this can be extra confusing because this
assignment y equals 1
could theoretically be hundreds of lines
later in the function
this is yet another reason to avoid
using global variables if you can
i also want to point out that other
languages like c and c
plus do not do things this way when i
run this function
it first prints the global i and then
prints the local i
that's why we get 0 and then 1 down at
the bottom here
i even compile with wall and w extra to
give me extra warnings and still
no warnings to be seen if i want to get
a warning for this kind of behavior i
have to compile with w
shadow the shadow here is referring to
the fact that what i'm doing
is called variable shadowing if i have a
variable and an inner scope like inside
a function
where i define a variable that has the
same name as
another variable in an outer scope like
the global scope
then this is called variable shadowing
in this case i would say that this
variable i
shadows the one in the global scope for
obvious reasons you should really try to
avoid this
if at all possible of course the same
goes for python
shadowing variables puts you on the fast
track to writing bugs
in case you were ever wondering this is
actually one of the reasons why
i define a separate main function rather
than just putting things down here
any assignments that i do down here are
actually in the global scope
and that means there's a chance that
they're being shadowed
i might expect an error if i try to
print y here but because the y down here
is in the global scope
i actually just print that y instead on
the other hand if i define a main
function then any assignments in here
that i do
are local to that function that means
anything that i do in here
i don't have to worry about affecting
things in other functions like
h now when i run the function i get the
expected error in
h that's all i've got on this topic
now that you know the rules go back and
watch the video again and let me know if
you get them all right this time
if you like the video please consider
sharing with your friends subscribing
and slapping that like button an odd
number of times
you